Mon titre est "plus bizarre que nous ne pouvons le concevoir : l'étrangeté de la science."
"Plus bizarre que nous ne pouvons le concevoir" est emprunté à J.B.S. Haldane,
le célèbre biologiste, qui disait : "En fait, je soupçonne
que l'univers est non seulement plus bizarre que nous ne le concevons,
mais même plus bizarre que nous ne pouvons le concevoir.
Je soupçonne qu'il y a plus de choses sur la terre et au ciel
que n'en rêve, ou ne peut en rêver, aucune philosophie."
Richard Feynman comparait la précision des prévisions expérimentales
de la théorie quantique à une marge d'erreur d'une épaisseur de cheveu
par rapport à la largeur de l'Amérique du Nord.
Cela veut dire que la théorie quantique doit, dans un certain sens, avoir raison.
Pourtant, les hypothèses nécessaires à la théorie quantique
pour pouvoir faire ces prévisions sont si mystérieuses
Que Feynman lui-même s'est trouvé forcé de noter que
"Si vous pensez comprendre la théorie quantique,
c'est que vous ne comprenez pas la théorie quantique."
Elle est si bizarre que les physiciens en sont réduits à choisir
entre l'une ou l'autre de ses interprétations paradoxales.
David Deutsch, qui intervient ici, a - dans "L'Étoffe de la réalité",
adopté l'interprétation de "mondes multiples" de la théorie quantique,
parce que le pire que l'on puisse en dire,
c'est qu'elle est incroyablement peu économe.
Elle postule un nombre important et croissant d'univers
parallèles -- mutuellement indétectables sauf à travers
l'étroit hublot que constituent les expériences de mécanique quantique.
Ça, c'est Richard Feynman.
Le biologiste Lewis Wolpert
croit que la bizarrerie de la physique moderne
n'est qu'un exemple extrême. La science, au contraire de la technologie,
fait violence au sens commun.
A chaque fois que vous buvez un verre d'eau, nous fait-il remarquer,
il est probable que vous absorbiez au moins une molécule
passée par la vessie d'Oliver Cromwell. (Rires)
Simple application de la théorie des probabilités.
Le nombre de molécules par verre est considérablement supérieur
au nombre de verres ou de vessies dans le monde --
et bien sûr, Cromwell n'a rien d'exceptionnel
ni les vessies. Vous venez d'inhaler un atome d'azote
qui est passé par le poumon droit du troisième iguanodon
à la gauche du grand cycas.
"Plus bizarre que nous ne pouvons le concevoir."
Qu'est-ce qui nous rend capable de concevoir quoi que ce soit,
et est-ce que cela nous apprend quoi que ce soit sur ce que nous sommes capables de concevoir ?
Certains aspects de l'univers seront-ils
à jamais au delà de notre compréhension, mais non au delà de la compréhension
d'une intelligence supérieure ? Certains aspects de l'univers sont-ils,
par nature, incompréhensibles à aucun esprit,
aussi supérieur soit-il ?
L'histoire de la science est une longue suite
d'éclairs soudains de compréhension, au fur et à mesure que les générations successives
ont accepté un niveau croissant de bizarrerie
de l'univers.
Nous sommes désormais si accoutumés à l'idée que la Terre tourne --
et non que le Soleil se déplace dans le ciel -- qu'il nous est difficile de réaliser
à quel point cette révolution intellectuelle a dû être dévastatrice.
Après tout, il semble évident que la Terre est immense et immobile,
et que le Soleil est petit et en mouvement. Mais n'oublions pas
la remarque de Wittgenstein à ce sujet.
"Dis-moi", demandait-il à un ami, "pourquoi dit-on toujours qu'il était naturel
que les hommes présument que le Soleil tournait autour de la Terre
et non que la Terre tourne ?"
Son ami lui répondit, "Eh bien, évidemment parce qu'on dirait que
le Soleil tourne autour de la Terre."
Wittgenstein répondit, "Mais à quoi cela aurait-il ressemblé
si on eût dit que la Terre tournait ?" (Rires)
La science nous a appris, contre toute intuition,
que des objets en apparence solides, tels les cristaux ou les pierres,
sont en fait composés presque entièrement de vide.
L'image classique en est que le noyau d'un atome est représenté par une mouche
au milieu d'un stade, l'atome le plus proche
étant dans le stade d'à-côté.
Il semblerait donc que la plus dure, la plus solide, la plus dense des pierres
soit en fait presque uniquement du vide, interrompu seulement par de minuscules particules
si largement espacées qu'elles ne devraient pas compter.
Pourquoi alors les pierres semblent-elles à l'œil et au toucher solides, dures et impénétrables ?
En tant que biologiste de l'évolution, voici ce que je dirais : nos cerveaux ont évolué
pour nous aider à survivre dans les ordres de grandeur et de vitesse
auxquels nos corps fonctionnent. Nous n'avons pas évolué pour naviguer
dans le monde des atomes.
Si c'était le cas, nos cerveaux percevraient probablement les pierres
comme pleines de vide. Les pierres semblent dures et impénétrables
à nos mains, précisément parce que des objets tels que pierres et mains
ne peuvent pas s'interpénétrer. Il est donc utile
à nos cerveaux de construire des notions telles que "le solide" et "l'impénétrable",
parce que de telles notions nous aident à diriger nos corps à travers
le monde de taille moyenne dans lequel nous devons nous diriger.
A l'autre bout de l'échelle, nos ancêtres n'ont jamais eu à
se diriger à travers le cosmos à des vitesses proches
de celle de la lumière. Si cela avait le cas, nos cerveaux seraient bien plus aptes
à comprendre Einstein. Je voudrais nommer "Monde du Milieu"
cet environnement à l'échelle moyenne duquel l'évolution de notre
capacité d'action s'est produite -- rien à voir avec la Terre du Milieu.
Le Monde du Milieu. (rires)
Nous sommes des habitants évolués du Monde du Milieu, et cela limite
ce que nous pouvons imaginer. Vous trouvez simples et intuitives
des idées telles que "quand un lapin se déplace à la vitesse
moyenne classique à laquelle se déplacent les lapins et les autres objets du Monde du Milieu,
et qu'il percute un autre objet du Monde du Milieu, par exemple une pierre, il s'assomme."
Puis-je vous présenter le général de division Albert Stubblebine III,
à la tête du département du renseignement militaire en 1983.
A Arlington, en Virginie, il contempla son mur, puis décida d'y aller.
Si effrayante que soit cette perspective, il allait se rendre dans le bureau d'à côté.
Il se leva, et contourna son bureau.
De quoi un atome est-il principalement composé ? se dit-t'il. D'espace.
Il se mit en marche. De quoi suis-je principalement composé ? D'atomes.
Il accéléra l'allure, presque jusqu'à courir.
De quoi le mur est-il principalement composé ? D'atomes.
Je n'ai qu'à faire fusionner ces espaces.
Puis le nez du Général Stubblebine heurta durement le mur
de son bureau. Stubblebine, qui commandait 16 000 soldats,
fut abasourdi par son échec répété à traverser le mur.
Il ne doute pas qu'un jour, cette capacité ne soit un outil courant
de l'arsenal militaire. Qui irait provoquer une armée
qui en serait capable ? Ceci provient d'un article de Playboy
que j'ai lu l'autre jour. (rires)
J'ai toutes les raisons de le croire véridique ; je lisais Playboy
parce qu'un de mes propres articles y était. (rires)
L'intuition humaine seule, instruite par le Monde du Milieu,
trouve difficile de croire Galilée quand il nous dit
que si on néglige le frottement de l'air, un corps lourd et un corps léger
arriveraient au sol en même temps.
Et c'est parce que dans le Monde du Milieu, le frottement de l'air est constamment présent.
Si nous avions évolué dans le vide, nous nous attendrions
à ce qu'ils atterrissent en même temps. Si nous étions des bactéries,
constamment ballottées par les mouvements thermiques moléculaires,
ce serait différent,
mais nous autres du Monde du Milieu sommes trop grands pour remarquer le mouvement brownien.
De même, nos vies sont dominées par la gravité,
mais presque inconscientes de la force de la tension superficielle.
Un insecte de petite taille aurait les priorités inverses.
Steve Grand -- ici à gauche,
avec Douglas Adam à droite -- Steve Grand, dans son livre
"La Création : la vie, et comment la produire", est franchement cinglant
à l'égard de notre obsession pour la matière.
Nous avons cette tendance à croire que seul ce qui est solide, matériel
est vraiment quelque chose. Des vagues de flux électromagnétiques
dans le vide nous semblent irréelles.
A l'époque victorienne on s'imaginait que ces vagues devaient être faites d'un genre de matière --
l'éther. Mais nous ne trouvons la matière solide rassurante que parce que
nous avons évolué de manière à survivre dans le Monde du Milieu,
où la matière est une fiction utile.
Un tourbillon, pour Steve Grand, est tout aussi réel
qu'une pierre.
Dans une plaine désertique de Tanzanie, à l'ombre du volcan
Ol Donyo Lengai, il y a une dune faite de cendre volcanique.
La beauté de la chose est qu'elle bouge physiquement.
Le nom technique en est "barkhane". La dune entière
se déplace à travers le désert en direction de l'ouest,
à une vitesse approximative de 17 mètres par an.
Elle conserve sa forme en croissant, et se déplace dans la direction pointée par les cornes.
Ce qui se produit, c'est que le vent fait remonter le sable
le long de la pente plus douce au dos de la dune puis,
à mesure que les grains de sable atteignent le haut de la pente,
ils redescendent en cascade sur le versant intérieur du croissant,
et cela fait avancer toute cette dune cornue.
Steve Grand fait remarquer que vous et moi sommes nous-mêmes
plus proches d'une vague que d'une chose permanente.
Il nous invite, nous lecteurs: "remémorez-vous une expérience
de votre enfance -- un souvenir clair,
quelque chose que vous pouvez voir, toucher, peut-être même sentir
comme si vous y étiez.
Après tout, vous y étiez réellement, à l'époque, n'est-ce pas ?
Sinon, comment vous en vous souviendriez-vous ?
Mais voici la grande révélation : vous n'y étiez pas.
Pas un atome de votre corps actuel n'était présent
lors de cet événement. La matière passe d'un endroit à un autre,
et s'assemble fugitivement pour vous constituer.
Quoi que vous soyez, vous n'êtes donc pas la matière
dont vous êtes constitué.
Si cela ne vous fait pas dresser les cheveux sur la tête,
relisez ce passage jusqu'à ce que ça vienne, parce que c'est important."
"En réalité" n'est donc pas une expression que nous devrions utiliser en toute confiance.
Si un neutrino avait un cerveau,
produit d'une évolution des ses ancêtres à l'échelle neutrino,
il affirmerait que les pierres sont en réalité constituées de vide.
Nos cerveaux sont le produit de l'évolution de nos ancêtres à l'échelle moyenne
qui ne pouvaient pas traverser les pierres.
"Réalité", pour un animal, est ce dont son cerveau a besoin
pour aider à sa survie.
Et parce que différentes espèces vivent dans différents mondes,
cela produit une fâcheuse diversité de "en réalité".
Ce que nous voyons du monde réel n'est pas le monde sans voile,
mais un modèle du monde -- réglé et ajusté par des données sensorielles,
mais construit pour nous permettre d'interagir avec le monde réel.
La nature du modèle dépend du type d'animal que l'on est.
Un animal volant a besoin d'un genre de modèle différent
de celui d'un animal marchant, grimpant ou nageant.
Le cerveau d'un singe a besoin d'un logiciel capable de simuler
un monde tridimensionnel à base de branches et de troncs.
Le logiciel qu'utilise une taupe pour construire ses modèles du monde
sera ajusté pour être utilisé sous terre.
Le cerveau d'une araignée d'eau ne requière pas de logiciel 3D,
parce qu'elle vit à la surface de la mare,
dans un monde à la "Flatland" d'Edwin Abbott.
J'ai émis l'hypothèse que les chauves-souris perçoivent les couleurs avec leurs oreilles.
Le modèle du monde dont une chauve-souris a besoin pour se diriger
à travers trois dimensions et attraper des insectes
doit être très similaire au modèle du monde requis par n'importe quel oiseau.
Un oiseau diurne, une hirondelle par exemple, doit accomplir
le même type de tâches.
Le fait que dans le noir, la chauve-souris se serve d'échos
pour entrer les variables dans son modèle,
alors que l'hirondelle utilise la lumière, n'est que secondaire.
Les chauves-souris, ai-je même suggéré, se servent de teintes perçues, "rouge" et "bleu",
comme des étiquettes internes utiles pour désigner certains aspects des échos --
peut-être la texture acoustique des surfaces, veloutée ou lisse, etc. --
de la même façon que les hirondelles ou, et bien, nous-même, utilisons ces
teintes perçues -- le rouge, le bleu, etc. --
pour désigner des longueurs d'onde plus ou moins grandes de la lumière.
Le rouge n'a aucune qualité intrinsèque qui en fasse une grande longueur d'onde.
Ce que je veux démontrer, c'est que la nature du modèle est gouvernée par
son usage, plus que par les modalités sensorielles utilisées.
J.B.S. Haldane lui-même avait son idée sur les animaux
dont le monde est dominé par l'odorat.
Les chiens sont capables de différencier deux acides gras, à des dilutions extrêmes :
l'acide caprylique et l'acide caproïque.
La seule différence, voyez-vous, est que l'un d'entre eux a une paire
supplémentaire d'atomes de carbone dans sa chaîne.
Haldane conjecture qu'un chien pourrait être capable de classer les acides
par ordre de masse moléculaire en utilisant leurs odeurs,
exactement de la même façon qu'un humain pourrait classer des cordes de piano
par ordre de longueur en se servant des notes qu'elles produisent.
Et il y a un autre acide gras, l'acide caprique,
qui est exactement comme les deux autres,
si ce n'est pour deux atomes de carbone supplémentaires.
Un chien sans expérience de l'acide caprique n'aurait peut-être
pas plus de difficulté à imaginer son odeur que nous n'en aurions
à imaginer une trompette qui jouerait, disons, une note plus haute
que nous n'en avons entendue venant d'une trompette.
Peut-être les chiens, les rhinocéros, et les autres animaux régis par l'odorat
sentent-ils en couleur. On pourrait faire exactement
la même démonstration pour les chauves-souris.
Le Monde du Milieu -- l'éventail des tailles et des vitesses
avec lesquelles, du fait de notre évolution, nous sommes instinctivement à l'aise --
est comparable à l'étroite bande du spectre électromagnétique
que nous voyons comme des lumières de différentes couleurs.
Nous sommes aveugles à toutes les fréquences au-delà,
sauf si nous avons recours à des instruments.
Le Monde du Milieu est l'étroite bande de réalité
que nous jugeons normale, par opposition à la bizarrerie
du très petit, du très grand, et du très rapide.
De même, nous pourrions construire une échelle de l'improbable.
Rien n'est complètement impossible,
les miracles ne sont que des événements extrêmement improbables.
Une statue de marbre pourrait nous saluer de la main: les atomes dont sa structure
cristalline est constituée sont déjà tous en oscillation, de toute façon.
Parce qu'ils sont si nombreux,
et parce qu'ils ne s'accordent pas pour aller
dans une direction donnée, le marbre
tel que nous le percevons dans le Monde du Milieu, reste solide.
Mais il se pourrait que tous les atomes de la main bougent soudain
dans le même sens, au même moment, encore et encore.
Dans ce cas, la main bougerait, et nous la verrions nous faire signe
dans le Monde du Milieu. Bien sûr, les probabilités sont si faibles
que si vous vous étiez mis à écrire des zéros
à l'origine de l'univers, vous n'en auriez toujours pas
écrit assez à l'heure actuelle.
L'Evolution, dans le Monde du Milieu ne nous a pas préparés à appréhender
les événements très improbables: nous ne vivons pas assez longtemps.
Dans l'immensité de l'espace astronomique et du temps géologique,
il se peut que ce qui semble impossible dans le Monde du Milieu
se révèle inévitable.
Une manière d'envisager cela est de compter les planètes.
Nous ne savons pas combien de planètes il y a dans l'univers,
mais dix à la puissance 20, c'est-à-dire 100 milliards de milliards, en est une bonne approximation.
Et cela nous fournit une manière élégante d'exprimer notre évaluation
de l'improbabilité de la vie.
[On] pourrait placer des sortes de points de repères
sur un spectre d’improbabilité, qui ressemblerait
au spectre électromagnétique que nous venons de voir.
Si la vie ne s’est développée qu’une seule fois sur…
si... si la vie pouvait... Je veux dire, la vie pourrait apparaître sur toutes les planètes,
pourrait être très commune, ou apparaître une fois par étoile,
ou une fois par galaxie, ou peut-être même une seule fois dans tout l’univers,
auquel cas, ce serait bien sûr ici. Et quelque part là dedans,
vous trouveriez la probabilité qu'un crapaud soit transformé en prince,
et autres événements magiques du même genre.
Si la vie n'est apparue que sur une seule planète dans tout l'univers,
cette planète est forcément notre planète, puisque nous sommes ici en train d'en parler.
Et cela signifie que si nous voulons nous en prévaloir,
nous sommes autorisés à postuler des événements de nature chimique dans l'apparition de la vie
dont la probabilité est extrêmement faible, un sur 100 milliards de milliards.
A mon avis, nous ne pouvons pas nous en prévaloir,
car je soupçonne que la vie est relativement commune dans l'univers.
Et quand je dis "relativement commune", il se pourrait qu'elle soit encore assez rare
pour qu'aucun de ces îlots de vie n'en rencontre jamais un autre.
Triste pensée.
Comment interpréter "plus bizarre que nous ne pouvons le concevoir"?
Plus bizarre que n'est concevable, par nature,
ou seulement plus bizarre que nous ne pouvons le concevoir, étant données les limitations
liées à l'apprentissage évolutif de notre cerveau en Monde du Milieu?
Serions-nous capables, par formation et pratique, de nous libérer
du Monde du Milieu, et d'atteindre quelque compréhension
intuitive autant que mathématique du très petit
et du très grand ? En toute franchise, je n'ai pas la réponse.
Je me demande si nous ne pourrions pas développer notre capacité à comprendre, disons
la théorie quantique, si nous élevions nos enfants en leur faisant jouer des jeux électroniques
dès la plus tendre enfance, avec une sorte de
monde simulé où des ballons passeraient à travers deux fentes sur un écran,
un monde où les comportements étranges de la mécanique quantique
seraient mis en avant par la simulation de l'ordinateur,
pour les rendre plus familière à l'échelle du Monde du Milieu.
Et, dans la même veine, un jeu vidéo relativiste dans lequel
les objets à l'écran subiraient des transformations de Lorenz, et ainsi de suite,
nous adapter à ces modes de pensée --
adapter nos enfants à ces modes de pensée.
Je voudrais conclure en appliquant cette idée de Monde du Milieu
à la manière dont nous nous percevons réciproquement.
Aujourd'hui, la plupart des scientifiques souscrivent à une vision mécanique de l'esprit :
nous sommes comme nous sommes parce que nos cerveaux sont câblés d'une certaine façon,
ou parce que nos hormones sont ce qu'elles sont.
Nous serions différents, avec une autre personnalité,
si notre neuroanatomie et notre chimie physiologique étaient différentes.
Mais nous autres scientifiques sommes illogiques. Si nous étions logiques,
notre réaction face à quelqu'un qui se comporte mal, disons un assassin d'enfant,
serait en gros: "cette unité comporte un composant défectueux;
il faut la réparer." Ce n'est pas ce que nous disons.
Ce que nous disons -- et j'inclue ici ceux d'entre nous qui sont le plus froidement mécanistes,
c'est-à-dire probablement moi --
ce que nous disons, c'est "Monstre répugnant, la prison c'est encore trop bon pour toi."
Ou pire, nous cherchons à nous venger, causant ainsi probablement
l'étape suivante dans un cercle vicieux de vengeance,
ce que, bien sûr, nous voyons chaque jour de par le monde.
En bref, lorsque nous pensons comme des universitaires,
nous considérons les gens comme des machines sophistiqués et complexes,
tels des ordinateurs ou des voitures; mais lorsque nous retournons à notre humanité,
nous nous comportons plutôt comme Basil Fawlty qui, vous vous en souvenez,
détruisit sa voiture pour lui montrer qui était le chef, quand elle refusait de démarrer
dans "La Nuit des gastronomes." (rires)
La raison pour laquelle nous donnons une personnalité à des choses comme notre ordinateur ou notre voiture,
est que comme les singes vivent dans le monde des arbres,
comme les taupes vivent dans le monde souterrain,
et comme les araignées d'eau vivent dans un plat pays dominé par la tension superficielle,
nous vivons dans un monde social. Nous nageons dans une mer humaine --
la version sociale du Monde du Milieu.
L'évolution nous a permis d'examiner et d'anticiper le comportement des autres
en devenant de brillants psychologues instinctifs.
Traiter les gens comme des machines,
c'est peut-être scientifiquement et philosophiquement exact....
mais c'est surtout une perte de temps gênante
si vous voulez deviner comment une personne est sur le point d'agir.
La manière simple et utile de modéliser une personne,
c'est de la traiter en agent rationnel, avec des objectifs,
des joies et des peines, des désirs et des intentions,
des remords et de la culpabilité.
Personnifier et imputer des intentions
est un modèle qui fonctionne si brillamment pour les humains,
qu'il n'est pas surprenant que le même logiciel de modélisation
prenne souvent le contrôle lorsque nous essayons de comprendre des entités
pour lesquelles ce n'est pas adéquat, comme Basil Fawlty avec sa voiture
ou comme des millions de gens crédules avec l'ensemble de l'univers. (rires)
Si l'univers est plus bizarre que nous ne pouvons le concevoir,
est-ce tout simplement parce que la sélection naturelle ne nous a rendu capables de concevoir
que ce que nous avions besoin de concevoir pour survivre
dans l'Afrique du Pléistocène ?
Ou bien nos cerveaux sont-ils assez polyvalents et élastiques pour que nous puissions
nous apprendre à nous échapper du cachot de notre évolution ?
Ou, pour finir, y-a-t-il certaines choses dans l'univers si étranges
que nulle philosophie d'un être, aussi proche du divin soit-il, puisse rêver ?
Merci beaucoup.